The universe is full of amazing coincidences. For example,
the earth lies an optimal distance away from the sun.
The sun in its turn is located in the ideal sector of the milk away for life to
originate and evolve.
There are other finer things which are not so easily noticeable,
but they remain important enough to be taken into account are further cognition
of the universe are these coincidences pure accidents,
or rather manifestations of some single underlying principle.
Let's try to get to the bottom of it.
The yellowed dwarf,
which is known as the sun and which gives us light and warmth every single
second is located on the periphery of the Milky way.
As it orbits around the center of our galaxy,
it follows the so-called co rotation circle.
This means that the rate of our sun's movement accurately follows the rotation
of the Galaxy's spiral arm, the which are Stella nurseries.
Thanks to this fascinating synchronization.
The Sola system hardly ever crosses the arms,
thus keeping a safe distance away from harmful super nerve flares and the heat
of active stars.
The diameter of this galactic orbit matters too.
If the were to lie closer to the center of the Milky way,
the great abundance of heavy elements would've rented the forming planets to
large and massive besides the gala galactic cause powerful ionizing
radiation would've thwarted any attempts of life to evolve and propagate on the
surfaces of the planets and their satellites.
On the other high, the further from the galactic center,
the much poorer the chemical diversity of elements. In this case,
Rocky planets of a rich chemical composition,
like our earth would never have been able to form the sun.
Would've been orbited solely by gas giants or rice giants at best.
There are some exciting coincidences, easily noticeable within the solar system,
too. For example,
consider this the earth lies the ideal distance from the sun and follows a
stable orbit with a small eccentricity.
Our planet's orbital trajectory is a remarkably close to an ideal circle.
If the trajectory is diameter shifted as little as 5% in any
the planet would either become icebound or would be shrouded in a dense cloud of
water vapor.
The bottom line is that any advanced life forms would cease to exist.
In addition, the sun itself has a number of extremely important features.
It is neither too hot, nor too cold.
And its life expect is considerably long.
Even though there forms a wide habitable zone around a hot star,
its life expectancy is generally small. Also its ionizing.
Radiation is much too powerful.
Gold stars like Fred dwarves.
On the other hand are capable of sustaining a habitable zone to narrow and
generally too close to themselves.
That is why more often than not planets within this zone are tightly locked to
their star.
And so are not equally heated up with the temperatures on the two sides
drastically different.
Someone will probably offer a counter argument here to this effect.
It isn't the earth that adapted to host humans,
but rather life adapted to the conditions already present here.
This is a rather sensible point.
Although if we delve deeper into the structure of the universe,
there are some facts that cannot be accounted for by this statement.
First of all,
it should be mentioned that celestial bodies can have stable orbits early in
three dimensional space in dimensions.
Other than that, the orbits of electrons in a substances atoms become unstable.
In other words, electrons and atoms,
either collapse to the core or fly away into space.
Thus atoms cannot exist in a multidi.
A universe of this sort would only have radiation and freely floating elementary
particles.
Another point to consider is that there are several fundamental values that all
contemporary physics is based on. They usually include the speed of light,
the gravitational constant, the planks constant.
There are mentor charge and the masses of the electron and the proton.
All these values have been arrived out experimentally and today are considered
to be mutually independent. However,
modern science cannot say why these values are exactly like that.
And no other way,
it is known that a free electron is a bit heavier than a proton and electron
system.
Without this inequality,
there would be no hydrogen around because otherwise at Saturn would immediately
turn into a neutron by the same token with no hydrogen around,
no stars would be able to form in the universe and heavier relevance would never
exist either with the values of the Q alarm interaction and the
powerful interaction slightly different from those gauged today.
No thermonuclear synthesis reactions in stars.
Interiors would be possible with an increased gravitational constant stars would
compress far too strongly.
This would inevitably produce a great Lera of large and hot stars with a short
lifespan after they burned out.
Most matter in the universe would be buried inside black holes and neutron stars
never to become material,
to help form planets satellites and other space objects.
By contrast, with a decreased gravitational,
a Intella gas would not be compressed enough to make thermonuclear reactions
self-sufficient in this case,
stars would simply never flare up and the universe would be filled with giant
brown wolves. This time,
a change in the electromagnetic interaction coefficient in any direction would
render chemical reactions and complex compounds virtually nonexistent.
On the other hand, if the interaction was stronger than it is now,
there would be no elements heavier than boron around then nuclear would
simply be torn up part by proton's electromagnetic repulsion,
heavy elements conform in the universe.
Thanks exclusively to a number of factors.
Favorably combined here are some more exciting coincidences
consider this.
It is thanks to a special state of carbon that helium is able to transform into
it known as carbon res.
This phenomenon plays a crucial role in the formation of heavy elements and t
hey're spreading across the universe.
It is thanks to carbon resonance that stars go supernova and shed their route to
layers. Atoms,
born in their interiors are scattered across space to form planets satellites,
asteroids, and other celestial bodies.
Besides carbon is vital for the Genesis of life.
Only carbon is able to create long and elaborate chains,
forming the base four and forking out into incredibly diverse chemical
compounds life.
As we know it can exist only when based on organic compounds that would never
formed, but for carbon.
So now it is clear that the universe itself,
as well as life in it and intelligent observers that is humans came to be only
thanks to a number of fascinating and not readily obvious coincidences
theories that would be able to account for this are usually beyond the scope of
physics and are rather to do with philosophy.
One of these is a referred to as the arthro principle,
even though the term itself was coined only in 1973,
the ideas it is based on had been voiced much sooner.
For example, we come across this idea in the works of Soviet scientist,
Gregor Italys dating back to 1958, where it is expressed to this effect.
What we observe is a part of the universe that is not random a priori,
but one that was made suitable for the Genesis and evolution of life by its
special structure.
This vision is referred to as the weak aro principle much later on
the so-called strong aro principle was formulated according to which the
universe is supposed to have certain properties that are favorable for the
evolution of intelligent life or to put it differently,
an observer is needed for the universe to exist.
The latter formulation is based on an idea used in quantum physics.
The observer plays a crucial role because their presence dramatically influences
the behavior of particles.
That is why the observer is indispensable in any quantum physics experiment.
We might also see it put this way.
The laws of the universe are the way they are because we can exist only in the
universe the way it is.
The aro principle implies that theoretically there may exist other universes out
there or else other parts of this single universe that would have a different
set of physical laws. However,
it is that either mankind is not able to observe those areas or those
hypothetical worlds cannot get trill without an observer assumption may be
further developed into a multiverse theory or a hypothesis where basic physical
constants may change their values as time goes by still observations
of the areas of the universe,
visible to us show that the fundamental values remain unchanged.
The concept of a multiverse defies description in the of science,
generally speaking,
the aro principle lies largely beyond the scope of the scientific view of the
world and requires a metaphysical approach.
Spanish LA lamb commented on this to this effect.
It's an attempt to account for the unknown using the unknown.
Also it is evident that the Aros clashes with the mediocrity principle,
the latter states that the area of space observable to humans isn't anything
extraordinary.
And there would be lots and lots of similar stretches within the universe.
The Milky way, for example,
doesn't boast any particularly unique structural features and its position in
the large scale structure of the universe does particularly stand out among
billions upon billions of other galaxies. In addition,
there is the principle of space homogeneity accepted in contemporary physics,
which means that natural laws are really the same from point to point in space.
The correctness of this postulate is confirmed by countless observations world
around us.
Mankind has been stirred by these questions since times a Memorial,
are we alone in the universe?
Is our home planet unique or rather more Earth-like worlds in the Milky way,
or is what we see just a kind of backdrops with whatever there is behind them
being something incredible that would our understanding and therefore
appears to be carefully concealed from us by the universe.
Science cannot give satisfying answers to any of these questions yet.
Otherwise it would probably bring about a downright revolution in our perception
of the world and upgrade our cognition to a whole new level as it is
everyone isn't entitle to their own personal opinion.
I.